[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue à l'émission
allons-nous l'émission ça décolle
réunion ensemble vous allez parler alors
allons-nous
[Musique]
dans la commune de bras pas non
aujourd'hui nous ça découvre la forêt
l'Eden Liberia le sentier de ma part là
allez allons-nous
bonjour monsieur bonjour comment il
était ça va vous voulez bien ça va ça va
dis-moi
une manifestation donc est-ce que un
seul randonnée ici où il y en a
plusieurs randonnée alors il faut savoir
que Nana 3 randonnées clés possibles la
première randonnée elle est un peu
sportif s'il y a personne
Apolline et après une autre sentier il
va du site de l'Eden jusqu'à la commune
de bois-pano d'accord et le troisième
le plus facile le plus familial c'est le
sentier de l'Eden lui-même qui émane
directement au site de l'Eden et il 1 km
c'est un sentier accessible à toute la
famille quoi d'accord voilà et en termes
d'entretien comment il se passe ici
occupe justement parce que nous l'ami
voilà elle est propre en fait une équipe
et là pratiquement tous les jours
sachant que le la forêt en elle-même
c'est en de 200 m d'altitude jusqu'à 900
m d'altitude et 450 hectares donc il y a
de quoi faire ben moi ça va jusqu'au
point de vue là-bas est-ce que nous
encore loin mais là où il est à une
quinzaine de minutes merci en tout cas
[Musique]
l'on retrouve mon moment rien que la
même Morgane
[Musique]
soleil
du site de l'Eden d'accord et donc ici
ce chant-là était appartient à Monsieur
duduro de volcompte donc il y a le site
a été abandonné dans les années 1920 et
dans les années 80 on a redécouvé à ce
site là et à partir de 2005 notre
association la reprise le site et donc
nous la redonne vie à ce chantier là et
donc le but c'est justement de faire
découvrir à nos visiteurs
le T de bras panne que ça nous nous
accueillir là-dedans exactement
et plus souvent prendre de feuilles
moins le thé sera de qualité d'accord
voilà donc vraiment important si on est
là que ça mais là où ça avoir été
impériale le goût c'est un goût
particulier on connaît au lieu de la
forêt ici donc le goût effectivement
sera particulier justement mais invite à
zota à venir goûter d'accord et c'est
une visite dit à peu près combien de
temps bah il faut il faut compter à peu
près 2h30 3h de visite le temps nous
sommes là-haut nous découvrent les
plantes endémique indigènes nous
découvrent le thé nous ça découvre aussi
mais pourquoi il appelle ça le site de
l'Eden pourquoi il y a pas la licence
les dernières alors bah tout simplement
parce que le monsieur qui était habite
là Monsieur duro de voir le compte que
le TN ancien député de La Réunion mais
il y avait sa maison ici d'accord sur le
site de l'Eden et donc il y a habité
vraiment au Paradis le matin quand il te
réveille mais il y avait un super point
de vue et donc c'est pour ça l'appel ça
le site de l'aide c'était les gaillard
donc là faut que ça aurait pu lui doit
le point de vue mais loin ou la pétrole
là ah ouais là où il y a à peu près 200
m bah elle est bon on a trouvé allez à
la prochaine en tout cas les Gaïa et ben
le point de vue là déjà moi elle est pas
là allons allez
sur le site de l'Eden et ben là tombe
bien
ça va bien bonjour ça va dis-moi
avec le gestionnaire nous discuter à
propos d'un animal magnifique que nous
retrouve ici en haut d'accord
reptile endémique de la Réunion
il appelle ça le lézard vadeo les
scientifiques appellent ça fait les
humains bourbonica et maintenant
toutes les forêts de moyenne altitude
beaucoup dans l'Est mais il trouve dans
le sud aussi dans le Nord et parfois
même des choses un petit peu
surprenantes mais fini trouver une
station de faits humains bourbonica
omaido d'accord et là justement qu'on
soit en train de dire le bunk
collaborateur travaille avec qu'il
faudrait que nous essayons trouver une
façon de mieux valoriser cet animal là
de bien fait montrer les visiteurs sur
le site de bien distinguer le fait du
mal endémique de la Réunion donc le fait
Zuma bourbonica mais aussi le faits
humain inexpectateur ça qui retrouve
entre Manapany et garantan Saba et
surtout bien distingué ces deux espèces
là des deux espèces exotiques donc deux
espèces que nous autres humains
Madagascar nous la ramène la Réunion et
comment le distinguons des méca alors
satisfaits en haut il faut regarder un
petit peu son dos et la façon dont les
couleurs est répartissent sont au dos
donc lui il a plein de tâches rouges
entre la tête et la queue me direz
d'accord sur un fond vert qui parfois il
tire un pneu sur le bleu métallique un
animal magnifique pour que ça il faut
protéger du coup mais parce que il est
rare parce que la peau et parce que son
habitat il diminue parce que les deux
espèces exotiques et bien les autres qui
vient concurrencer cette espèce là et le
fait Zuma de Manapany le lézarder
manapani excusez-moi il y a encore plus
grand celle-là elle est carrément danger
critique d'extinction c'est vraiment de
joyaux de du patrimoine naturel de notre
île que nous essayons en tout cas bel et
bien gaillard mais bien sûr en tout cas
vous pouvez
une table d'orientation derrière alors
que ça ne peut retrouver nous on va
retrouver le massif de la Caroline juste
par là aussi si nous retourne comme tu
peux devant nous noirs on retrouve le
massif du Liberia et Bonneville alors
ici des bananes
encore ici là nana la ville de
Saint-André juste là bon et pour finir
d'un trou là de Nana la ville de
Saint-Médard
qui est vraiment
riche ok la réunionnais
et tout ça on nous a un prochain épisode
de l'émission de nous ça fasse une
soirée de la communauté la forêt des
Hauts de Montvert la semaine
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]